good afternoon i am paulo cravedy i'm an
associate professor
of nephrology at uh icon school of
medicine at mount sinai new york
and today we are going to talk about a
transcriptomic
signature specially resolved analysis of
the nephron structure in chronic kidney
disease
so kidney disease is a major health care
problem over 800 millions people
worldwide
have some sort of uh kidney
problem and kidney disease is the 11th
leading cause of mortality worldwide
and importantly up to 7
million of people die
because of lack of access to renal
replacement therapy
such as dialysis and transplantation
so the functional unit of the of the
kidney
is called the the nephron so there are
about
1 million nephrons in adult kidneys
and they are composed of
one portion that is called glomerulus
and another one
that is called the tubal in the
glomerulus
what happens is the major filtration of
the blood
and the the formation of the initial
urine
and then through the the past through
the through the tubals
um the urine gets concentrated and the
elements that
are important for our organism gets
reabsorbed
and some other substances that have to
be eliminated get released by this
uh fraction of the of the of the nephron
and here is a picture at electron
microscopy
of one glomerulus
and it's important to keep in mind that
nephrons cannot be regenerated in adult
life
so we are born with a determined number
of nephrons
and these nephrons have to be preserved
and kept functioning for all the extent
of our life
importantly if we um focus
a little bit more on the glomerulus how
it works
we notice that the the glomerular
filtration barrier that is
what allows the blood to be filtered the
urine to be filtered from the blood
into the urinary space is formed by
three different structure
so one is the podicides which is a
unique
kind of cell that is in the outer space
of the glomerular filtration barrier
and these cells are post-methodic cells
and so they do not proliferate then on
the other sides on the
blood side of the chromosomal filtration
barrier
we have endothelial cells that are also
unique because they present particular
fenestration that are responsible for
the first filtration activity of the
glomerular
barrier and between these two cells we
have the basement membrane here that is
a very thin layer of matrix
that is composed by different um
chains of of collagen that only the
the podocytes can can produce
so we as we said we're born with about a
million nephrons
and over time patients that develop
chronic kidney disease have a
progression
reduction of these nephrons up to a
certain extent
that requires the replacement of the
renal therapy either by dialysis
or by transplant and the overall
idea of renal disease progression is
that
progressive loss of functional nephrons
leads to the hypertension
of the remaining one and these leads
initially
represents a compensatory mechanism but
that over
on over time this leads to the
loss of protein in the urine and
progression
of the renal disease so
um it's important to highlight that the
homeostatic balance between the
glomerular cells
and the glomerular basement membrane or
gbn
and which is vital for the maintenance
of the glomerular ultrastructural
integrity
and normal filtration function is
altered
during chronic kidney disease or ckd
and the treatment of ckd has been
historically
focused on slowing its progression by
systemic approaches
that are causing many side effects
and are not specifically targeting the
glomerulus
but as we just saw is the
the main um functional unit of the
of the kidney so to
develop new therapeutic approach
approaches it's important
to get a better understanding of the
glomerular biology
and to have a better understanding of
the molecular mechanism
that determine progression progressive
glomerular disease
it's also important to keep in mind that
not all glomeruli and tubules are
affected
in the same way at the same time
even in the same individual disease or
tissue
or gender so there's really um
a variability across the each each
nephron so studying them all together
like uh like here here's the is the
biopsy of a kidney that is highlighting
the different structure the different
glomeruli and different
tubules and does not allow to
have enough granularity to understand
the variability
across the different glomeruli and so
by doing so by doing this black analysis
that has been done so
um until until recently we lose the the
information
that is in crucial to get the molecular
mechanism
important for the renal disease
progression so there are
different techniques to get more
insights about the about the single
cells or single structure of the
glomeruli
here today we are talking about the um
what um is called the nanostring
technology that
allows to have transcriptional
information of the different structure
in kidney biopsy and the the way it
works
is by um staining uh
the biopsy the renal biopsy with
antibodies
that have only go um um
holy ghost that are conjugated to these
antibodies
then the biopsy is analyzed and we can
um
define the regions of interest
where we want to understand the the gene
the transcriptional
phenotype and then once with these
regions of interest are defined
and the biopsy is undergoes
uv and cleavage of that of the oligos
from the
from the antibodies and then these
oligos get
amplified and so it will give us the
information about the transcriptional
profile of each single area
that we were interested in so um
by we were interested in using this
technology to better understand the
the renal disease pathophysiology and so
we started analyzing
um a few samples of patients with normal
disease
or with a genetic renal disease
with immune mediated diseases
and with a primary renal disease that is
not
genetically um driven so
the first disease we focused on is
alport disease
so this condition is characterized by um
abnormalities in the glomerular basement
membrane brain
and manifests clinically by the presence
of proteinuria or protein loss in the
urine
and um the
the presence of glomerulus carrying and
hearing loss
and ocular manifestation because the
same um
collagens that are present in the in the
gbn that are abnormal in this disease
are present
also in the year and in the and in the
eye and
here are the genetic abnormalities that
um
that drive this collagen disease
and can be in most of the cases x-linked
so
associated with with with sex especially
with the in the
male sex but there are also forms that
are autosomal and could be recessive or
autosomal dominant
the second disease we focused on is
membranous nephropathy
as you can see in this representative um
slide
membranous nephropathy is associated
with the thickening of the membrane of
the glomerular
um uh of the glomerular membrane um
in the in the kidney and this is due
to the presence of antibody against
podicide
uh proteins in most of the cases against
one podocyte antigen that is called
pla2r or phospholipase 2 receptor
and the formation of the immune
complexes in situ
on the on the podocytes leads to
podocyte
injury and then proteinuria or protein
loss
and progressive renal failure the third
disease we focused on is called focal
segmental glomerulosclerosis
so the name means that only some
glomeruli so it's focal
and some sections of the glomeruli so
it's segmental
are interested by the sclerosis so focal
segmental glomerular sclerosis
and so we know that the
the histological re and characteristic
of these diseases as we just
mentioned but the the pathophysiology
why this disease is happening is still
unclear
and similar to the other diseases this
um
this condition is also characterized by
proteinuria
and progressive renal failure so we
decided to use these three diseases
because they are really characteristic
and
um of most of the glomerular
diseases that can happen in the kidney
and here are the the biopsies that we we
characterize
so we took two biopsies of patients with
alcohol disease
two from patients with a focal segmental
chromospherosis
one patients with membranous nephropathy
and one
healthy um kidney that was obtained from
manufacturing
so the the the renal function that is
measured by serum creatinine
was a little bit variable across across
the different
conditions but as you can see almost in
all these conditions there were some
degree up to a severe level of
of proteinuria so we took the biopsies
of these patients
and then we defined the regions of
interest or and our eyes that in our
case
were the glomeruli so we picked the
glomeruli in each of these biopsies
and then we took the tubular areas in
each of these biopsies
with the ultimate goal to define the
transcriptional
profile in each of the single areas
of each single biopsy of each single
patient
and so we process this
this data here are the details how we
did this this processing
and the first thing we did was to make
sure that the quality of
our data was good and we
found that the sequencing depth was
consistently high
yielding high confidence counts across
all the samples so
the the procedure were just fine
and we also verified
that the there was a good dynamic range
across all the samples in terms of
gene expression so here you can see the
different
diseases stratified by glomeruli and
tubular areas
and each of um this and each of these
little dots
represent one gene that is more or less
expressed and as you can see there are
genes that are blue
and others that are white so it means
that there is a wide range of expression
if this range was more narrow this would
have limited
our our capability to capture
differences
across glomeruli and across patients
so this was the first time we used this
technology so we wanted to make sure
that the data made made some sense so
the first thing that we did was to
compare the expression of genes in the
glomeruli
versus the tubules and we were happy
in noticing that the glomeruli were
expressing
um uniquely podocyte genes that were not
expressed in the tubules
and they were also again the glomeruli
and expressing
genes that were a characteristic of
glomerular endothelial cells and
majestical cells that can be found
only in the glomeruli not in the tubes
we next um put together all the tubals
and glomeruli
from the different um patients
and again we were reassured
in seeing that in these principle
component analysis
that represent in a two-dimensional way
all the different
um the um dimension represented by
the expression of each single gene
that the tubals um cluster different
from the glomeruli so indicating that
the
the gene expression profile of the
tubules and the glomeruli was different
as predicted as these are very two very
different
regions with two different structure and
different
functional um capacities
importantly we also notice that in gray
you can see the normal
um tubals and normal glomeruli from this
normal biopsy
and all the the other ones the other um
squares and dots and and triangles
that are um colored are from patients
with diseased kidneys
and the gray and the colored dots really
well
segregate one from another so indicating
that there is a difference
as predicted between disease and normal
kidneys
we next went more granularly
and we tested each single disease so we
started from
upper disease the genetic disease and it
was compared between
against the normal grameoli and as you
can see here in
in the square the tubal segregates
differently from the tubules of output
patients
and the dots against um was well
separated from the dose of the outboard
patients uh interestingly we also
noticed that in light green and
in in red there we represent the two
biopsies
one was from a male one from a female
that has slightly different
um genetic um abnormalities
and so we were able to notice to
appreciate the difference between the
two biopsies
and within each biopsy each of these
dots represent the different glomerulus
so you can see that um even though
all the glomeruli from the same biopsy
cluster
in the same area there are different uh
differences across different glomeruli
um within the same biopsy which made
this this kind of analysis
very very interesting and we next
um we did this volcano plots that allow
us to define the differences in the
expression of
genes uh so on the x-axis we have the
fold
change so the more they are on the left
or on the right side
the higher is the difference in the in
the expression between the normal versus
the output glomeruli
and on the y-axis we have the
statistical significance so the ones
that we have in the
um top left and top right are the genes
that are more
um highly uh more differentially
expressed between the
between normal and and alpha syndrome
and
we were able to identify some genes that
we knew
being differentially expressed and
importantly we found
differences also between the two between
the two patients
um when we compared the two pension the
male and the females
more in in detail we were able to
identify
to to pinpoint the single genes that
differed between between the two between
the two
the two patients we did the same thing
for focal segmental chromosclerosis
again here we have the glomeruli of the
fsgs patients and in gray the patients
the
the normal glomeruli that
segregates differently and here are the
the volcano plots are all together on
the left
on the left in the middle for the the
the male patient and on the right for
the female patient
and if you look at the volcano plot on
the left
putting together both biopsies you can
see that the most
highly significantly upregulated gene in
the fsgs patient was the c3
and we were pleased in seeing c3 because
it is one of the complement components
and we had
um we have been interested in studying
complement
in this in this condition and indeed is
not
uncommon to see complement deposit in
fsgs
nor in the plasma of patients with fsgs
and in patients that have low c3 so that
have a consumption of complement
there is a lower survival of
of the kidney in patients with the
fascists so
overall suggesting that complement um is
important in the pathophysiology of this
disease similar to what this special
and transcriptional analysis was
indicating
we arrived to this uh conclusion
through a different path but is is
really
intriguing that um the same path is
uh independently by this
um special transcriptomic analysis
and to formally uh prove that that
complement is implicated in the
pathophysiology of the disease
um we and others have done some mouse
experimental data
in an animal that don't have c3 and as
you can see in green the mice that don't
have c3
have less albuminuria or proteinuria or
the disease severity
than wild type controls upon exposure to
adremycin that is one of the of the
strategies to induce fsgs in mice
um we um next move
to um our immune mediated disease
membranous nephropathy and here we also
found a pathway
that we were not really aware of that
was
upregulated the il4 pathway here you see
in the volcano plot an upregulation of
one of the gene of this pathway
and in the um
and in the expression um
pathway again il-4
ranked amongst the top pathway and
when we looked into the literature we
found that indeed
th 2 cytokines so cytokines by t
cells that release um that produce il-4
were a characteristic of patients with
membranous nephropathy
so again so these these data with the
spatial transcriptomin
where partially confirming the previous
literature but also pointing at
new genes that in the future we will be
interested in studying and studying more
so the next step for this um kind of
study
will be to um assess the differences not
across biopsies
but across the various glomeruli and
tubules
which was the main initial reason why we
did
we use this technology to start with
and as a step further we use the
computational
um so the question is are there
differences across cells
within a single glomerulus and to answer
this question we use a computational
strategy
to make a deconvolution of the cells
that are present in each glomeruli
and in each tubal that we selected in
our region of
interest so using this computational
algorithm
we were able initially to define
differences
in the cell company composition between
glomeruli and tubules
which was expected but was kind of our
control that this algorithm was working
just fine
and here just by looking at the
composition
um sorry of the different um cells
in the glomeruli and tubules we were
able to identify for example
in the glomeruli some cell subset that
we're not really um
expected to be part of the glomeruli
and similarly so in the in the tube
and if we just look at the composition
of the different cell subset in the
glomeruli
and in the tubules we were able to
identify already some
differences across the different um
across the different
biopsies and and this was true
for the glomeruli as well as
for the for the tubals
so the next step here will be
to assess the gene expression profile
not just in each glomeruli but in each
cell subset within
a single glomerulus which is expected to
give
us important information about the
variability
across the different glomeruli and
understand whether glomeruli that have
similar histological feature have a
similar transcriptional profile
or vice versa if um grameoli
that look different have uh similar
um transcriptional um pathways that are
activated
so that's will be um we believe
um very important to better understand
the molecular mechanisms
that are responsible for the renal
disease progression
and um finally to um
together with the transcriptional
profile
we also tested the protein expression
profile
uh within the kidney so the same slides
slides actually serial slides were also
stained
for different um markers protein markers
and the the purpose of this staining was
to on one hand validate
the the transcriptional profile so that
if we saw
upregulated gene we could confirm that
also the protein were upregulated
but was the other idea was also
to define um
to better define the single structure in
the
in the in the kidney based on the the
expression marker
that um could allow us to identify
um regions in smaller regions of
of interest and to test their their
profile within these regions
and these are the preliminary data that
we
obtained so far with this um with this
technique
where there are many proteins of these
um
panels that are not really over or
underexpressed but there
are two subsets of proteins that are um
um
express highly express or express
um or um or express
or lowly express that will be um
informative to better understand um
and integrate the transcriptional
profile data
so um overall to um to conclude and
summarize our data
we observed differences between alport
fsgs and membranous glomeruli
as well as between glomeruli and tubals
within each disease
we found that not all glomeruli or
tubules are affected in the same way
even within the same kidney and the
spatial profile
can clearly help us understanding such
differences
it also seems that males and females are
often
um affected with ckd different
differently and this
was clearly observed in our outport and
fsgs samples
this could be attributed by the the
variability across samples but could
actually be something that is really sex
dependent
so understanding their differences at
transcriptional level
and also at the protein level could lead
to more specific and personalized
therapies
so um in conclusion the spatial
profiling of gene expression
and we think is a powerful tool that
will allow us to answer some very
important question
about the mechanism of disease
progression in glomerular lckd
such as alport fsgs and membranous
nephropathy
thank you for your attention